est ce que c'est une référence à ton
divorce peut pour dire la vérité avant
l'émission
j'ai eu un appel de ton agent qui m'a
dit jean-luc faut pas lui parler de son
divorce alors je comprends pas comment
on peut faire une chanson qu'on entend
partout à la radio qui s'appelle tu es
parti sans laisser de tendresse et puis
qu'on n'ait pas droit de parler de ton
divorce parce que ça fait quand même
bien référence à une séparation - ouais
mais tu sais les chanteurs sont tous des
menteurs
ouais c'est 300 me à diamant aussi enfin
ces trois cent mille personnes par an
sont dus ces cancers douche entre le
france et pas son bateau ouais
pourtant c'est une galère mais ça se
passe comme ça que les autres émissions
leur dis faut pas parler de ça ils n'en
parlent pas non si tu veux je trouve
bord douze mois c'est dévié j'ai suivi
une campagne en duo a subi une campagne
a bien accepté de faire des photos dans
paris match
non mais paris match était c'est une
réponse à toutes les choses absurdes qui
sortait dans certains canards un peu
bizarre si tu veux mais moi il a fallu
que je fasse une petite mise au point
qui était d'ailleurs tout sympa si tu
veux et je n'avais pas du tout envie que
les gens pensent que j'étais l'artisan
d'une autre campagne parce que bon les
gens qui venaient planqués qui me
prennent en photo en moto et tout ça
dans le tournoi les voiries matches cet
été pour simplement dire ok pour effet
en effet c'était pas au beau fixe chez
moi et que c'était donc le drame
mais il s'est passé quoi en gros c'est
le fait d'avoir essayé de chanter
ensemble qui vous a séparés sont de
l'avis ses chances et toutes façons
sépare jamais vraiment avec la mère de
ces vingt pages avait eu une interview
dans paris match
tu disais que tu avait accouché toi même
tu as femmes et que enfin clos révision
des enfants tapent highway et que tu es
avec coupé toi même le cordon ombilical
de la petite gloria ouais je conseille
pas d'ailleurs c est ce que ça a émoussé
le désirent un peu d'être agent c'est
rien ça s'est il faudrait voir un psy si
tu veux pour ça il va poser la question
avant de le faire si si j'vous j'étais
pas très chaud pour pour assister à la
naissance moi je préfère si tu veux que
le pré derrière la porte et puis tu vas
arriver à la fin du spectacle c'est
formidable c'est un show la naissance
d'un enfant c'est à la fois merveilleux
et déstabilisant pour un point hommes
c'est vrai tu disais toujours aurélie et
le casque bleu de mes doutes tapis de
caisse que bleuté doute là matin tu
doutes haye ap doute non plus fort
maintenant inclus le casque bleu
seignosse landes
c'est formidable transformer non non ça
va non tu auras jamais six enfants quoi
peut-être pas avec la même femme